(powerful music)
- Welcome to a Conversation With History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of The Institute
of International Studies.
Our guest today is T. M. Scanlon
who is the Alford Professor
of Natural Religion,
Moral Philosophy, and Civil
Polity at Harvard University.
He is the 2008 Howison
Lecturer at Berkeley.
His publications include
What We Owe to Each Other,
The Difficulty of Tolerance:
Essays in Political Philosophy.
Professor Scanlon, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
It's a pleasure to be here, Harry.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in Indianapolis
and spent the first,
I guess, almost 20 years of my life there
before I went east to go to college
and sort of never returned.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- Well, my father was a lawyer.
And he loved the law and the Constitution.
So legal questions,
questions of legal policy
were an important part of
the dinner table conversation
as I was growing up.
And he and my mother had also
both been quite interested
in philosophy as undergraduates,
although that wasn't their major.
But it certainly had a big impact on them.
So the idea that there was
this subject called philosophy
was something I knew about even though
I never read a philosophy book
or it never appeared to me
as something we talked about much.
So when I went to college, I
saw these courses, philosophy.
So I thought well, Mom and
Dad used to talk about that.
It sounded interesting to me.
I'll give it a try.
- And before you went to
college, give us an example
of the kind of discussion you would have
around the table about
some constitutional issue.
- Well, my father,
he was a litigator and he
sometimes defended libel suits.
So he was very devoted
to the First Amendment.
So we often talked about
the First Amendment.
And one particular moment I remember
that had a huge impact on me.
I was going for a walk with my father
sometime in the early 50s.
And we were arguing about
an article that had appeared
in the Indianapolis Star, which
was a client of my father's.
He always had to defend them,
although he wouldn't have
defended their politics which
were very different from ours,
very very conservative.
And they had had a
particularly misleading series
of articles on some
subject I don't remember.
And I was incensed by this.
My 11-year-old anger was
up and I said to my father,
how can they be allowed to
publish this kind of thing.
It's misleading people about
these important questions.
And my father said, "But who's to decide
"what they can publish
and what they can't?"
And I felt as if I'd been
turned to stone on the moment.
I was so ashamed of myself.
This was a really interesting,
difficult question
I couldn't answer.
I had no idea.
I felt caught between the sense
that it's a very bad thing
that this sort of thing is out there.
But this reply seemed absolutely right.
And so the tension between these ideas,
the obvious rationality apparently
of restricting expression
versus, on the other hand, the idea
that really wasn't proper really stuck me.
And it's something I
continued to think about.
And I suppose, I don't
know how many years later,
20 years later or something,
when I was first writing
on political philosophy,
that was the first thing I wrote about.
- And as a young person,
before you went to college,
were you engaged in debates and arguments?
Did you bring a philosophical bent
to your way of thinking
early even before college?
- I suppose I was drawn
toward abstract thinking.
But I was mainly interested
in math and science.
I suppose mathematics
was my main interest.
And so, I think I had a
bent for abstract thinking,
but I didn't really think about philosophy
in the usual sense.
I wasn't occupied with
paradoxes or the sort of thing
that one might have been thinking about.
- And as a young person, any mentors
other than your parents
who shaped your thinking?
High school teachers or something?
- Well no.
The high school teachers
that had the biggest impact
on me, again, were my math
teachers who inspired me
to work hard.
And they got me sort
of interested in logic
because we did proofs
and things like that.
And I found that, proofs
in geometry for example.
I wasn't so interested in geometry,
that is, the structure of space.
But I was very interested in the idea
that you could prove things,
and the puzzle of discovering proofs.
So it was natural that when
I went into philosophy,
one of the main things I
got interested in was logic.
And that was my main subject of inquiry
for the first 10 years or so
that I was in the subject.
But they didn't really
turn me on to philosophy
in a direct sense, no.
- And where did you go to
do your undergraduate work?
- I was an undergraduate at Princeton.
And then I went to England
for a year to Oxford,
really just taking a
year out to try to decide
whether I could take the
plunge and become an academic
which seemed to me a very strange
choice of life at the time
rather than go back to
Indiana and practice law
which is what I'd always been
assuming that I would do.
Then, I decided philosophy was something
I couldn't give up.
So I went back to the
U.S. and went to Harvard
to be a graduate student.
And then after just a few years
went back to Princeton to teach.
So I followed a very small circle.
- And what was it about
philosophy that drew you in?
Was it this base in
logic and argumentation
that you had brought to the table?
- Well initially.
It's a good question.
I don't fully know the answer.
Certainly initially, questions about logic
and the structure of
argument were the things
that most appealed to me, the
technical side of the subject.
In fact, I wasn't interested
in moral philosophy at all.
I suppose I was a kind
of logical positivist,
as that was a popular but
already much criticized doctrine
when I was a student.
But I was rather skeptical
of whether there was
anything interesting
to be said about moral
and political questions from
a philosophical point of view.
So I only took a moral philosophy course
because I was told I had to.
It was a requirement for graduation.
When I took it, I thought it was terrific.
(laughs)
I really got engaged with the questions.
Although in the beginning, I
was mainly interested in them
sort of from a technical point of view.
I thought that formal decision theory
and welfare economics
were a way of answering
questions of social philosophy
and individual morality.
And that's what my first teacher
in the subject had been into.
And he really turned me on
to that side of the subject.
But after a year or two of
working in it in that way,
I became sort of frustrated with the ...
I loved the formal techniques,
but I found the results
a little bit arid, and I
thought there was more to it.
So I then broadened out and
got interested in other things.
- I think our audience
would be curious to know
what exactly a philosopher does.
And a way I like to get at this problem
is to ask you, for the
benefit of the students
who might watch this, what are the skills,
the temperament required to do philosophy
as you're helping us understand
what it is a philosopher does?
- Well the skills, I think,
are a taste for analysis
and skill at drawing distinctions,
the patience to keep doing it,
and the tolerance for a
fair amount of frustration.
Because it is inherently difficult.
It's no accident, I think,
that philosophical questions
are difficult in this way.
Philosophical questions,
to my mind, are questions
that are raised by some
way of understanding life
and the world that we're
naturally drawn to use,
but which can't be answered satisfactorily
using that method.
So for example, if religion
is an important way
of understanding life and the world,
then the question whether God exists
is an important philosophical question.
It's a philosophical question
because religion raises it.
Everything depends on
whether there is a God.
But answers within a religion presuppose
that there is a God.
So you don't discover
whether there is a God or not
by reading scripture.
So similarly, if science
is the important way
of understanding life and the world,
then it's a philosophical question:
what's the difference
between a chance regularity
and a genuine law of nature?
And how can you tell
that you're seeing one
rather than the other by
simply looking at a finite
number of experiments?
Everything about empirical science assumes
that that's true, that
science doesn't just discover
coincidental regularities.
It discovers kind of
how nature really works.
And it does that by inferring
from a certain number
of carefully constructed experiments.
So those questions are questions
that science presupposes and depends on,
but they can't be answered
in the laboratory.
So they're philosophical questions.
So philosophical questions are questions
that are, in this sense, external
to some normal way of thinking.
Because they're external,
there isn't an obvious way
of how to answer them.
So the philosopher is a bit at sea,
out there in the void, so to
speak, trying to synthesize,
trying to make up or find
some grip on these questions.
And there are also philosophical questions
that don't come from some
established system of thought
like religion or science,
that are just perennials,
like do we have free will?
How do we understand our
idea of moral obligations
to each other?
We come to, we're taught, we learn,
we develop some sense
of what our obligations
to other people are.
And we can reason using those
commonly understood standards
about what we ought to do
and what we ought not to do.
But there is a question: why
should be care about that?
Why should we be willing to sacrifice
in order not to do something that's wrong?
That's not gonna be a
question that's answered
within the ordinary moral principles.
Because those principles presuppose
that there is something important there,
but it isn't obvious what it is.
So philosophy then takes
up the task of trying
to give an explanation of
why these are something
we should care about.
And that's a task of
philosophy that's as old as,
you know, as old as the Greeks.
It's what Socrates and Plato were doing
and all of their successors.
So philosophy is difficult because
it is external in this way.
And for that reason, it requires patience.
Because students tend to get frustrated.
'Cause there isn't an obvious answer.
They say, "What's the answer?"
So well, here's a plausible answer.
Here's the reasons why it
seems like a good answer.
But of course, there are difficulties.
And you're not a good
philosopher unless you're also
always looking around
to find the difficulties
with what you've said.
But not everybody has a tolerance
for that kind of tension.
- So if I can try
to cut into some of
what you're saying here,
what is it you as a philosopher
makes personal choices about the problems
that you're gonna address?
Do you have any thoughts
about what has led you
to particular topics?
For example, problems
of political philosophy?
- Well as I said earlier, I got interested
in problems of freedom of speech
because they were a topic of conversation.
They just seemed inherently
puzzling and important.
But I also was interested in questions say
about the foundation of mathematics
which didn't come up because of ...
So it's hard to say
exactly what makes one ...
There are many things out
there that are puzzling.
And it's hard to say what draws you
to one particular puzzle
rather than another.
I suppose it has to be
a puzzle about something
that you really care about.
And it also has to be something that you
feel able to say something about.
There are questions about let's say
the metaphysics of time or
other things which are puzzles,
but I don't feel like I
got a real grip on 'em.
So I tend not to be drawn to those.
- But an area that you decide on,
do you wind up researching
the area in order ...
Because what you're trying to do
is formulate the right questions
for a particular subfield or endeavor.
- Well, people divide about this.
And one can be embarrassed by the answer
one finds oneself giving.
Of course, when you think about a field,
if it's a questions in philosophy,
there are a lot of smart
people have thought about it.
And it certainly makes sense
to go see what they had to say.
Some people think that's
the main thing you wanna do,
develop an understanding
of how this developed,
what Kant had to say about it,
what criticisms there
were, have that lens.
And that's certainly a very
important form of inquiry.
I'm a little bit embarrassed to say that,
although I've learned an
awful lot by studying Kant,
Mill, Hume, other people in
the history of philosophy,
I tend to wanna just go in
and think about it myself.
So,
I am drawn to just get the bearings
and think about these
answers as possible answers.
But then, when it comes down to it,
you gotta decide yourself.
So you have to at some
point switch off the reading
and just start thinking and scribbling.
- And what does creativity
in philosophy look like?
- Well, it isn't, I think, on the whole
just flashes of insight.
It comes out of noticing things
that other people haven't noticed
because you've been
putting your mind's eye
on them more carefully,
and being willing to consider objections
to what one would normally say
more seriously and more penetratingly.
So I think that the real
original bursts of creativity
in philosophy come to others
who haven't made the discovery
in a certain sense as a revelation.
But also saying yes of course,
I actually was somehow
aware of that already.
That is, a good philosopher finds things
in the materials that are
really available to everybody
which once a person says
them, you think oh yeah.
Right.
There was that problem there
and I was kind of turning
my eye away from it.
So I think insight in philosophy comes
from careful attention to the questions
as they present themselves to us.
- And in reading your essays
in The Difficulty of Tolerance,
which I will show our audience,
it seems that in this process, clarity,
both in the sense of
the way you're thinking
about the problem, but also the expressing
of that clarity so the reader will come
to the same insight
that you're leading to.
Both of those are very important.
- That's certainly the
most important thing.
And then one goes back
and rereads one's essays,
the thing that one is
most dissatisfied with
is that one hasn't been
as clear as one thought
one must be.
And so, the constant drive
to try to make it clearer
is one of the most important things.
That's right.
- And this book has a collection of essays
essentially on political philosophy
as a subfield of philosophy
and of your work.
What is distinctive about
that focus of your attention?
- What's distinctive
about political philosophy
as opposed to other kinds of philosophy?
- Yeah, yes, yeah.
- What's distinctive about
it as I see it is that
it has to do with our
relations with each other
that are mediated through
the institutions we share.
Moral philosophy has to do, by my likes,
primarily with what we owe
to each other as individuals.
And a lot of those are just questions of
am I gonna tell you the truth?
Am I gonna kick you?
Am I gonna keep my appointment?
Questions like that
which don't necessarily
depend upon larger scale institutions.
Although they may have different effects
because they take place
within such institutions.
But some of what we owe to each other,
we owe to each other as participants
in large scale institutions.
We pay our taxes.
We vote.
We take part in political processes.
And we feel obliged to
obey and accept the results
of those processes, and to not interfere
with other people's participation in them.
So the question, well we're
born into these institutions.
We just find them operating around us.
Why should we accept them?
What demands can we make on them?
If people think they're being
treated improperly by them,
when is it appropriate
for them to complain?
When are their complaints justified?
So those are, they're
moral questions in a sense,
in a large sense,
because they're questions
of what we owe to each other.
But they're not just, so to speak,
questions of personal interaction.
They're questions about the
conditions of our participation
in large scale systems of cooperation.
- Now when you are
dealing with these issues
of political philosophy,
the rigor, the logic is still required.
But you're dealing with
an area of passion,
where people have very strong views
that aren't always driven by logic.
How do you reconcile those tensions?
Or does your background in philosophy
make it easier for you to do?
- Well I don't know if it makes it easier.
It imposes a kind of discipline on me
about focusing my attention.
But I guess I would
register just a little bit
of skepticism about this
contrast between logic
on the one hand and the
emotions on the other.
Logic of course, it's a formal subject,
operates according to definite rules.
And you can turn it into a
mathematics like calculus.
But let's not think about
logic, but as a reasoning
more broadly when I'm drawing inferences
about whether I'm really seeing a chair,
or a person, or a blackboard,
or when I'm reasoning
about what's likely to happen.
Is it gonna rain or something like that.
That's reasoning in a looser sense.
So I'm responding.
I take certain evidence
as grounds for drawing
a certain kind of conclusion.
I can take evidence as grounds
for drawing a conclusion.
I can take facts such as
the fact that I told you
I was gonna be here as a
reason to do something.
I think both of those things are reasoning
in exactly the same sense.
Even though the second
one motivates me to act
maybe in a way that the first doesn't
in a more direct and obvious way.
So I think and even when we
are, as people might say,
acting out of emotion, when
people act out of emotion,
they're acting for a reason.
If I'm angry at you,
that means I'm inclined
to take the fact that you wouldn't like it
if I said something as a reason to say it.
So I think we can't understand emotions
without looking at them
as you might say complexes
of tendencies to see things as reasons.
So I think that the idea
that when I'm reasoning
about whether it's gonna
rain or about whether
I should go to Berkeley
or not, that's one thing.
But acting on emotions is something else.
I think the idea of
responding to what we see
as reasons, either
consciously or unreflectively,
is common across these domains.
And there's not a big
separation as is often suggested
by the use of the terms.
- In this collection,
you direct your attention
to a number of really important problems
in political philosophy: human rights,
freedom of expression,
tolerance, urgency, and so forth.
And I'm just curious.
In this realm, is it
more important to go back
and look at what the great
philosophers have said
as you carve out your position?
Is this an area where you
find yourself doing that
more of the time than in
other areas of philosophy?
- Well, as I said earlier,
one can be a barist
by the answers one finds in this.
But I think the answer is no.
(laughs)
I think for some reason,
I don't know quite why,
but my writings and moral philosophy
have paid more attention to
the great writers of the past,
particularly Hume, Kant,
and to some degree Aristotle
I think as the main exemplars,
than what I do in political philosophy
which tends more to just
look at the questions
or to deal with the way
they've been presented
by more recent figures, such
as my teacher John Rawls,
and look less back.
I don't know why that's true.
But it just does seem to
me to be a matter of fact.
- Now, what led me to look
at these particular essays
was which I gather were
written from the 70s
to the early 1990s.
They deal with a number of issues that
in the post 9/11 world are,
you know, have come back
in a very powerful way and so on.
Before we get into some of your ideas
on some of these issues, I'm curious as to
how you think your ideas,
once they've been put down,
are affected by the
changing times basically?
For me, it struck me that
everything you'd written long ago
still applies today.
And I'm just sort of
curious as to what extent
there is any impact in
the relevancy of the times
on what you do,
and would want to impel you to go back
and read this stuff and
see if it still stands up.
- The first article that I published,
which is the first article in that book,
is called A Theory of
Freedom of Expression
which I wrote in the early 1970s.
It begins with a quote
from Justice Holmes.
It said, "When you see
that speech is gonna cause
certain harms, there's nothing
more rational than trying
to restrict speech in order
to prevent those harms."
But he then says, (laughs)
"When we understand how history works
"that we see that we have to hold back."
He was talking about cases that arose
around the time of the First World War,
and anarchist agitation, and so on.
But as cycles of political
controversy come around,
if they raised essentially
the same questions
about is Congress
entitled to act to prevent
perceived serious harms at the expense
of limiting citizens'
rights to participate
in the political forum to
express their ideas, or whatever.
That's a perennial question.
And it's not surprising
that it keeps coming back.
So I was thinking about it in the context
of the Vietnam War reading
someone who had written about it
at the time of the First World War.
And now we've got another war on.
So national security issues
are again on the forefront.
So those similar questions come back.
But they don't always
come back in the same way.
Another way in which questions
of freedom of expression
frequently arises has to do
with sex and social mores.
So restricting pornography or literature
that's thought to be obscene or offensive
is another perennial topic.
But at the time I wrote that essay,
and even the subsequent follow-up
to it in the later 1970s,
the main forums in which that demand
that expression on sexual
matters should be limited
was mainly coming from people who wanted
to prevent sex from being discussed.
There was a sense of sexual
repression was the way
the pro-speech side would
have described the worry.
But by the time you get to
the later 1970s and beyond,
it's coming from feminists
who are worried about it
as a question of equality.
So if we wanna preserve a social outlook
in which women are respected,
we need to restrict expression
that perpetuates stereotypes, or suggests
that women want to be dominated
or are properly dominated.
And similar questions
come up about hate speech
with respect to racial equality.
So the idea that we
need to restrict speech
in order to preserve a
certain social outlook
is a perennial.
But exactly what the issue is,
whether we want to prevent people
from being too concerned with sex
or whether we want to preserve equality,
those things may change.
And so one has to think about
them in a different way.
- And so the role of a philosopher,
and his contribution really,
is to define these problems
in such a way that these
waves of different groups
who come forward do not
undermine our basic understanding
of the principles that are at stake.
- Well one has to refine our understanding
of the principles that are at stake
in order for us to see how
we can, on the one hand,
do justice to the claims
that people are making,
but still somehow explain
how we can preserve
a climate of open discussion
which we think is important.
How should we understand the
values that are in conflict?
And here's the thing that's
always on the agenda.
What kind of judgment are we making
when we're saying although
this value is important,
restricting expression for that reason
would violate a right.
And therefore, that draws a line.
What kind of a judgment are we making
when we appeal to a right?
That's the underlying question
that keeps coming back.
- So help us understand
now for our audience
what you came to see as
the important dimensions
of freedom of expression.
And we're in this realm
of political philosophy
where we're talking about our relations,
people's relations with
their institutions.
- Right.
Well when I first thought about it,
I thought in this first article I wrote,
I was very taken with the
idea of individual autonomy.
It's important for citizens
not only to be able
to make up their own mind
about important questions
about life and politics,
but also to have their
relations with each other
and with government defined
by the idea that they are autonomous.
So I thought that recognizing
other people's autonomy,
recognizing citizens'
autonomy drew a sharp line.
It's incompatible with
seeing citizens as autonomous
for government to decide
this can't be published
because it might lead them to
draw some false conclusion.
Right?
Whether the conclusion's
false is up to them to decide.
That's what it means to
treat them as autonomous.
Later on, I came to think
that that restriction
on the way speech can be
restricted was too tight.
And one should adopt a more you might say
I don't know if I wanna say practical,
but a more instrumental view
that the main reason why
government can't have unlimited power
to restrict speech has to
do with the dangerousness
of giving governments that power.
And so, we were properly more willing
to allow a government say
to restrict some kinds
of false advertising
than we are to allow them
to restrict what they take
to be false political speech.
Because government is,
one might assume although
this isn't always true,
somewhat less partisan
and less untrustworthy
and less likely to abuse its power
in the realm of false
advertising about products,
about how dangerous your
lawnmower is or something,
or how long your car is gonna last,
than it is in the realm of deciding
what are true answers to the
basic political questions
of our times.
So I thought that my original idea that
it's autonomy that sets
the limits was too rigid.
And one needed to take into
account the question of
how dangerous is this?
How dangerous is it for government
to have a power of a certain sort?
So there's a lot of drawing
on historical experience
from past governments
to see what would happen
if government had the power to do this.
When we think there's a right,
what we think is it's too dangerous
for government to have that power.
So they don't have it.
That is to say, we have a
right that they don't do it.
- And going back to this idea of autonomy,
you make this important distinction about
the information that people
need so that they can
really be an independent agent
versus, you know, helping
somebody with the means
to take action which the
thought might lead them to.
- Right.
A friend of mine said, when
I was writing about this,
he said, "Well I hope you'll explain why
"people can't publish their recipe
"for making nerve gas at home."
So I incorporated that (laughs)
into my article.
And so I think people are
entitled to the information.
They shouldn't be blocked
from having the information
they need to make political decisions.
But I don't need to know
how to make nerve gas
in my sink in order to
decide who to vote for.
So I thought in that original article,
and to some degree I still think that,
information about technical matters
isn't necessarily something
that can't be restricted.
Whereas information that
just might lead me to decide
that single-parent health
care was a good thing,
or was a bad thing, isn't
something government can restrict
because they think I might
do the wrong thing with it.
- Now in the wake of 9/11, we developed
a new scenario of the possible
threats to the United States
which one could argue provide
an opening for the state
to make a new case
with regard
to what its domain should be
with regard to freedom of speech.
One thinks of the notion
of a surprise attack,
the notion that you're dealing
now with terrorist groups
that might have access to
nuclear weapons and so on.
In light of these changes,
what impact,
or what intuitions do you have
about how you might change your thinking
on matters of free expression, if at all?
- Well, as I said earlier,
these seem like new questions,
but in a sense, they're old questions.
Although I think what
changes is not so much 9/11,
but new technology changes
things to some extent.
One of the most important
things we'd wanna protect
in protecting freedom of expression is
the people's opportunities for advocacy,
and people's opportunities to find out
whether other people agree with them
about the propriety of
particular political actions.
It doesn't seem to me that
the state is threatened,
that al-Qaeda presents a
worry in that dimension.
Although Muslim imams may make
inflammatory statements,
but it seems to me that that's something
you gotta live with.
I think that's an old question.
I think it's a settled question.
I don't think 9/11 changes it.
Although it gets us more excited about it,
just the way at the time
of the First World War
people were excited about
anarchists making speeches.
And I think there's a general tendency
of the government to exaggerate the degree
to which they need to
protect us by restricting
people's simple statements of advocacy.
There's another question,
on the other hand,
which is the communications
between conspirators.
So maybe they do need
to be able to restrict
the way people can
communicate with each other
if they're actually
in the process of carrying out a plan.
I think that's not an
issue of freedom of speech.
It may become an issue of privacy.
And there it does seem to me,
again, that's a separate area.
But it's settled.
You need to have some kind of prior cause.
You can't just start listening
to everybody's
communications with everybody
because you're gonna fish around and see
if you can find somebody
who's in the process
of developing a conspiracy.
But where there's probable cause to think
these people might be
engaged in a conspiracy,
it seems to me it's not an
issue of freedom of speech,
that they might be able to do it.
Nor I think is it an issue of privacy.
But the main question where
freedom of speech comes in
is this area of public advocacy.
And I think that the risks
that public advocacy
might turn more people on
to being against the government
is a risk that we simply have to accept.
- Now how bound are these discussions
by the kind of polity that you
are talking about basically?
And how do you think about those matters?
Because your essay on human rights
is making an effort to
sort of think about well,
what are the circumstances under
which one should intervene?
And what we're talking about,
is it universal or is it not?
- Your question raises
two difficult issues.
One is relativism.
And the other is the
permissibility of intervention.
I think it's important to keep
these two things separate.
The first is, I believe
in an open society.
I think that defensible
institutions have to be ones
that the citizens to whom they apply
and who are asked to accept and obey them
can object to, can raise
questions, can protest against.
That seems to me a basic requirement
of the legitimacy of institutions.
And I'm inclined to say
that's universal, right?
That isn't just a parochial
view about institutions.
It's a view about what people
can demand of institutions
as a condition for being
willing to accept them
and go along with them.
They have to be able to protest.
So, I'm not a relativist about that.
Now the exact form that
protest needs to take
or the exact form the
political institutions take,
there's a certain range
for variation there.
But I think that there's a
fairly strong universal truth.
Now, we hear there's some other society
where people aren't allowed to protest.
That properly changes
our view of the authority
that that government has
to speak for those people.
But it doesn't immediately
follow that we can go out there
and tell 'em they've got
to do something different.
Well, we can tell them.
I think we can say we don't think that.
Your citizens, it seems
to us, have a good case.
But can we cut off their oil?
Can we stop trading with them?
Can we send in the Marines?
Those are all much more
difficult questions.
So I think one wants to
separate the question of
do these standards apply
from the question of
what role do outsiders have
in intervening to try to change people
in one direction rather than another.
But in addressing that question also,
it's important to remember that they
don't all have the same
view about these things.
Relativism is often put
in a we versus they.
Of course, we think that human
life is special or sacred.
We think that people have these rights.
But of course, in this other society,
they don't think.
But they are almost never
unanimous about this.
The portion of they
who've been put in jail
for their political beliefs
don't normally think
that it's okay to put people in jail
for their political beliefs.
(laughs)
So in deciding what's right and wrong
about what's happening in their country,
you gotta take into account
the claims of the people
who are in jail as well as
the people who are outside it.
But that said, there's
still a further question
about what are we able or
entitled to do about it?
Sometimes, we are able to do something,
maybe by expressing disapproval,
maybe by withdrawing trade.
But those are difficult questions
although those questions also are asked
within a universal moral framework
about what's permissible
to do to somebody else?
When are you permitted, or even required,
to intervene to protect somebody
against horrible treatment?
And when are you required
as an outsider to stay out?
That's a general moral question
that applies across boundaries.
- As I listen to you and
as I look at your essays,
I'm struck by how relevant this all is.
And what's in the back of
my mind is the question
how does philosophy make an impact?
In other words, obviously,
you make an impact
on the field of philosophy,
on the students you have.
But I must honestly say
as I was reading this,
I said hey, you know, more
people should be reading this.
Because it has a cleansing
quality on the mind
as you think about the issues
that you're actually reading
in The New York Times.
- Well, I'm extremely pleased
you'd say that, Harry.
And of course, it's a
matter of frustration.
In the early 1970s, some friends of mine
and I got together and founded a journal
called Philosophy in Public Affairs.
And it's amusing, or maybe embarrassing,
to go back and read the
preamble that we wrote
in which we said something
like what you just said.
That we think that
philosophy has something
to contribute to moral issues
that are centrally concerned
with the issues of our time.
And we, by founding this
journal, we want to,
on the one hand encourage philosophers
to address themselves more
to these practical issues
than they have before.
And second, to bring their
thoughts to a wider audience.
Looking back, I think we even said
philosophy has something in
agreement to the understanding
and even the resolution of these issues.
That seems wildly optimistic looking back.
But looking back now,
whatever it's been now,
35 years,
I have to say that I think we
were really quite successful
on the first front.
That is, philosophers did,
not simply as a result of what we did,
but partly because of
the spirit of the time,
come to turn their minds much more
in succeeding decades
to practical questions.
I don't think we succeeded
very well in getting people
outside the philosophical
community to attend to.
I think that the
subscriptions of that journal
never got beyond 3,000, I believe.
It was cited in a few Law Review articles,
but not much beyond there.
So it's hard to crack that frontier.
I've written a few things in
The New York Review of Books,
maybe in a few other journals like that.
But I don't know that they've
gotten a very wide audience.
I once participated with a similar group,
the same group of folks, in
writing an amicus curiae brief
for the Supreme Court.
This was in the case
about assisted suicide.
And I'd done a similar thing earlier
with another group of people in a case
having to do with academic
freedom and freedom of speech.
And that one, the one
about freedom of speech,
was seemed to be never noticed by anybody.
But the one on assisted suicide
got a fair amount of play.
It's sometimes referred
to, often negatively.
And a couple of magazines actually
mentioned it in their stories.
Reporters called me up about it.
But I was struck by the fact that
when the reporters called me up,
they never wanted to ask me
why do you guys think this?
Or why do you guys think that?
Rather, the only question
they wanted to know was
who do you guys think you are
that you should be
pronouncing on this subject?
Which I thought was a
little bit surprising.
- So it's really their attitude toward you
as opposed to the
substance of your position.
- These pointy-headed
academics getting up there
trying to tell us what to do.
That seemed to be the attitude.
- In one of the essays in this collection
that also struck me was this
one as we just talked about,
the one on human rights.
And is there anything that
one would like to add now
in the face of ...
You know, if you look at the 90s
and the emphasis of human rights,
and how would the political
process in essence
corrupted some of the
basic insights we had
about human rights and
turned it into a notion
of really changing societies
that couldn't be changed.
- That's right.
- And you addressed that in your essay.
- Well I do, although only in
one paragraph or one sentence.
And I wish I said, look even if you think
it's permissible for people to intervene,
that people who are torturing people
and throwing them in
jail don't have a right
not to be interfered with,
still, we've got to
look at the question of
how effectively could we intervene.
And that may be a very important barrier.
I think I said that in
more or less those words,
although it was buried in
one particular paragraph.
If I were writing it again,
I might puff that up.
But I would, if I were
writing that essay over again,
and sometimes I wish I could,
I certainly would say something different
for a couple of reasons.
That essay was really a kind of product
of the late Cold War.
It came to be in an
interesting way having to do
with your previous question
about how philosophy
can become influential.
A friend who was running
an Institute for Philosophy
and Public Policy at the
University of Maryland
organized a series of working groups
bringing together people from the Academy,
mostly philosophers and
political scientists
and some economists,
with decision makers of
various sorts from Washington:
congressional staff people,
in this instance on human rights,
some congressional staff people,
actually a couple of people from Congress.
I think Harkin was there,
'cause he'd written this amendment:
the Harkin Amendment
which restricted the sale
of weapons to countries that engaged
in systematic violations of human rights.
And also, there was a procurement
officer from the Pentagon
who participated in this.
So we met four times over
the course of several months,
arguing about it.
And then we wrote papers for a volume.
And that was it.
That was what it was from.
So when I was talking there
about Human Rights as a Neutral Concern,
that's the title of that essay,
this was what, the early 1980s I guess,
I was still thinking about the East/West,
the Soviet Bloc,
and a NATO dichotomy
that is that human
rights were being accused
of being an expression of bourgeois values
as against the proper economic rights
that were supposedly being recognized
in socialist countries.
And so I was trying to argue about
how human rights really
are concerns that span
that disagreement about
there may be disagreement
about economic policy, but
there shouldn't be disagreement
about whether it's alright
to put people in jail
without any kind of due
process and things like that.
So that was my idea of the
neutrality of human rights.
But if you fast forward
now to our own time,
the Cold War is over.
Human rights are now being
charged with a kind of
lack of neutrality.
But that's not the dimension along which
neutrality is being disputed.
It's rather cultural differences
between Asian values and Western values,
or between societies organized
along religious lines
and societies that are not.
So the relevant dimension
around which the neutrality
of human rights might be challenged
is quite different now than it was then.
And also, we've had more
experience with intervention,
as you say, so I would highlight it.
Although I firmly believe
that's a paragraph
that was important.
I'd highlight it more if
I were reading it now.
So those are two examples
of the way in which change
of events can certainly
change what one would say
and what one would
emphasize if one were trying
to write about a question philosophically.
- Do you feel impelled at all
to try to rewrite the essay?
Or is it something that ...
- Well, I thought when
I was putting together
this collection, I thought
should I try to rewrite this?
Or write in an afterword?
And of all the essays in that book,
I was most tempted to do that
with respect to that one.
But several people I knew who had written
follow-on essays that referred to that
had basically made the central points
that I would have made.
And so I would have had
to go back and discuss
what they had said.
And again, I think it would
have fitted a little oddly
in the volume.
So I decided to leave it
as it was and live with it
and think that maybe later
I'll write another essay
which I do hope to do.
I just gave a seminar
with a political scientist
and Amartya Sen, an economist at Harvard,
on rights and human rights.
So I'm thinking about it again.
And I might write something else.
- One of the other essays in here,
interestingly enough,
and again, I must say
the topics you touch on in this book
have come to the fore again even though
they always exist through time.
It's just they before us more powerfully.
You talk about tolerance.
And tolerance "is a recognition
of common membership
"that is deeper than these conflicts,
"a recognition that others are
just as qualified as we are
"to their contributions
or definition of society."
Are you pessimistic
about the way we act on tolerance
based on the insights
that you give us here?
- Well, I'm pessimistic maybe,
but perhaps at a different level.
What I said in that essay
was that the main issue
of tolerance is that we all care about
what kind of society we live in.
And tolerance arises out of the fact
that that society belongs to all of us.
None of us has ownership of it.
And recognizing that it's
other people's society
just as much as ours involves recognizing
their entitlement to participate
in the evolution of its mores,
to dress the way they want to dress,
to engage in the kind of sexual life
that they want to engage in,
to be religious or not
religious as they choose.
All those things are private
decisions in a certain sense.
But they have a public dimension.
And if a lot of people
make one choice or another
along with those dimensions,
it changes what society
is like for all of us.
So I wanted to say that
tolerance is a difficult doctrine
to accept because it
involves putting ourselves
in the hands of our fellow citizens,
and recognizing we gotta
live with these people.
And so we're gonna have to let the society
go the way the most of
them decide it's gonna go.
So, I can be pessimistic about that.
I can say I'm firmly
committed to tolerance.
But I don't like the way that society
becomes more and more and
more saturated with sex.
And more and more people
are talking about it
or are concerned about it.
I don't like that change of events.
But, you know, I can't
go out there and tell 'em
what they can put on the billboards
or what they can write in the magazines.
I have to accept that I
don't own the society.
And now society's becoming more religious.
I'm not religious.
So living in a society
in which I'm an outsider
in a certain way is not comfortable.
And maybe it'll evolve to that point.
But living in an open society
involves taking that risk.
That's the price of really being connected
with your fellow citizens
at the deeper level
in which you recognize
them as fellow citizens
who own this thing just as much as we do.
So I'm always worried about
the consequences of tolerance,
but I'm firmly committed to
accepting the consequences.
You were asking more
about am I worried that
people are gonna become less tolerant
and try to impose on me.
Well yes, that's always a threat.
That certainly is a threat.
But I think we've done pretty well.
The demand that people be prevented
from living the lifestyle they want,
expressing the values they want
because it's gonna have a bad
effect on social mores is,
as I've said, something
that's always being raised.
But so far, I think we've
done reasonably well
at beating it back.
And so, one always wants to be worried.
That's what the ACLU and
organizations like that are for.
And they're necessary.
Because one always has
to be worried about that.
But that's a different kind of pessimism.
I'm not so pessimistic.
I'm hopeful on that.
Although I just have to
keep my fingers crossed
on the other front about
where it's gonna lead.
- So I guess, is it fair to say that
philosophy's stake in this is
clarifying what the issues are
with regard to something like tolerance,
helping us understand,
defining the questions
so we see what the problem
is in the bigger picture?
- See what the problem is
and see why a certain answer
is one that we should rest with.
As you said properly, philosophers have,
anybody has a responsibility
to try to participate
in public discussion.
And maybe, philosophers
have thought a lot about it.
You think it would be a good thing.
Many people may not think that.
They ought to try to get
their ideas out there.
Having said that, it may be
an embarrassing thing to say
that philosophy is to a very high degree
a first-person subject.
I write about tolerance because
although I wanna be tolerant,
I think but look, it's got this price.
If we're at all gonna be tolerant, then
what kind of society are
we gonna be living in?
So I feel that tension.
And I wanna get an answer to the question.
Given that I think it has this cost,
why am I so concerned with it?
And that goes back to my
interchange with my father
when I said how can they
let the newspaper say
this kind of thing.
People are being systematically misled
about this subject, and that's gonna have
very bad political consequences.
And my father said, "Who's to decide?"
(laughs)
So, similar I might say about tolerance.
Who's gonna be the police?
Are we gonna say that
somebody can just say,
okay, now we've got the society we want.
You can stop thinking
about how you want to live.
You got to accept this.
No, we don't want anybody
to decide that way.
Well,
why not?
Can we say more about that side of it
to make us see more clearly
why that's the right side to come down.
And then think about all the
objections you can raise.
And how can those objections be answered.
So we're really trying
to answer a curiosity
that comes from within.
- If students were to watch this program,
and they find your discussion
of your own career interesting,
how would you advise them
to prepare for the future
either as a philosopher
or as somebody who draws philosophy
into their way of thinking,
whatever that might be, and profession?
- Well, studying philosophy,
for the topics we've
just been talking about
in political philosophy,
studying political
and constitutional
history is a very good way
to get a sense of the form that
these questions have taken.
And I think that they come more alive
for people often when they read them
not directly in the context
of a philosophical theory,
but by seeing how they played out
in actual practice.
So if you read one of Anthony Lewis' books
about the First Amendment
or about the rights of the
accused, Gideon's Trumpet,
that gives you a feeling
of the way in which
rights play out in actual
historical context.
I think that gets you going.
But then the next step is
to try to think about it
in a more theoretical way.
And at that point, it's
probably better to read.
What you need to do is
read some philosophy.
Or better, get into a
class where you can argue
with people who wanna argue
about it philosophically
so you can get some
experience in doing it.
- And you seem to
emphasize at the beginning
of our discussion your
background in logic and math,
that learning to think about things
other than the things you
wanna think about really.
- Right.
Well of course, those were
things I wanted to think about.
(laughs)
That was kind of an indulgence,
sort of like doing Sudoku.
Pure pleasure thinking about
whether you can find a proof of something.
I think studying that sort
of thing is great discipline.
It's something some people enjoy.
Some people don't.
It isn't essential for doing philosophy
although maybe it helps a little bit.
But a lot of people do
philosophy who aren't
drawn to those technical questions.
- Now in terms of your
lecture here on campus,
and what your current research is on,
I guess you're working
on the problem of blame.
Is that ...
- Yes, it's embarrassing
enough to be sitting
next to somebody on an
airplane and they ask you,
"What do you do?"
And you have to say you're a philosopher.
It carries it to an extreme if they say,
"What are you working on?"
And you say, well for
the last couple of years,
I've been thinking about blame.
(laughs)
They really start edging
away from you on the seat.
- Well if you were flying
jetBlue, you (mumbles)
- That's right; that's right.
But I partly got into this by thinking
about questions of free will.
That is everybody thinks,
or many people think,
that in order to be blamed for something,
we have to have done it freely.
And that raises the question:
are we really free in a relevant sense?
So that's a deep philosophical,
familiar and deep philosophical question.
It seems to me though
that in order to address
that question, you gotta first get an idea
about what blame is.
'Cause we don't think that in order
for people properly to
say that you're ugly,
or handsome, or that you
have a nice singing voice
or whatever, you've got
to have freely chosen
to have those merits, or
demerits as the case may be.
So something particular
about the kind of appraisal
that moral criticism or praise involves
that it seems to entail the condition
that that kind of criticism
is only appropriate
if the person has control over whether
they are like that or not.
Why should that be true?
So that's the sort of
question that leads you
into asking what are we
doing when we're doing this?
And there are various
candidate answers out there.
And I didn't find many of
them very satisfactory.
So I got interested in the
question of thinking about
what blame really amounted to.
Then that led to a lot of thinking.
And it changes in mind
over a period of years
thinking about it.
- Well I know that we'll
look forward to your book
when it comes out.
And people will watch the lecture.
But in the meantime, I
wanna thank you very much
for being our guest today
and giving a sense of philosophy.
And let me show the book
that we talked about,
The Difficulty of Tolerance:
Essays in Political Philosophy.
Thank you very much for this.
- Thank you, Harry; I enjoyed it.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation With History.
(powerful music)